[Music]
if the 1930s San Francisco Joseph B
Friedman and his young daughter Judith
are sitting at the counter in a soda
parlor Judith has just ordered the
milkshake vanilla or strawberry we may
never know when the milkshake arrives
Joseph watches as little Judith
struggles seated on the parlour stool
she is unable to reach the mouth of the
striped paper straw protruding from her
shake Joseph in a moment of vision
modifies Judith straw he inserts a screw
into one end and using a piece of dental
floss crushes the paper between the
threads of the screw creating a series
of tiny equidistant corrugations
after removing the screw the straw is
able to bend over the side of the glass
and Judith is able to savor her
milkshakes
Joseph initially markets the new
flexible straw to hospitals to help
patients drink while reclining but
eventually with the marketing and
business savvy from his sister Betty the
bendy straw becomes a beloved utensil of
every child in a regular household item
you
[Music]